barbara is with us in newark delaware
hi barbara welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
well i retire in may after 21 years of
nursing
wow and i i wanted to know
whether i should be paying off my house
with some of my 401
or whether i should keep paying it
monthly
so when how i know you like paid off
houses how old are
how old are you and a half say again
66 66 and how much is in your 401k
i have two we switch so i have two
92 in one of them and six um
698 in the other wow look at you
a millionaire nurse
just i'm terrible spending so i'm new to
you terrible
good at working i'm uh well i'm proud of
you this is pretty incredible it's
awesome way to go how much of this
you obviously didn't inherit your 401k
money did you have big inheritance money
that made you a millionaire
nothing no you just worked just hard
work
21 years of nursing yeah
that's impressive barbara started late
after my children went to school
yeah wow and yeah at 46 years old you go
do this right now you're 66 20 or
45 years old so uh correct don't tell me
you can't it's too late my gosh look at
barbara
and so uh uh what's it take to pay off
your house
179. i'll do it tomorrow i'll do it
tomorrow absolutely
okay now just take the 27 292 and just
yeah what about the taxes that are
involved you'll have to you have to set
some taxes out there'll be
a full tax rate on that and so get in
touch with your tax professional
yeah get in touch with your tax
professional so you know how much to
pull out because you need to pull out
enough to cover the taxes
as well okay good news is the taxes
won't be due
until uh this time next year right
okay because you're doing it in this
calendar year and so
when you file the taxes is when you'll
have this this tax bill due
on this but you don't want it to
surprise you or sneak up on you or
anything and so
do you have any other monies other than
these 401ks
uh no those are my two big savings i
have 6 000 in my savings account
and when i cash out everything here in
may i'll have about 18 000 put into
emergency fund
good good okay well done kiddo
so what's your house worth thanks when
uh well it's about 280 to 300 in this
market
okay good for you yeah so i'm talking to
a lady that's worth a million two yep
uh with a with a paid for house and um
her house represents about a third of
her net worth
you know what you are you fit the exact
template of what we found when we
studied millionaires and we stayed 10
000 of them
for the everyday millionaires project
and you were you're just
exactly in there i mean you're
incredible i am so proud of you
well done thank you dave thank you honor
to speak to you
this is yeah dad this is really the the
theme hour
no excuse excuses